je dois dire que je peine à comprendre
quel intérêt aurait eu la grande
distribution a caché des stocks de
masques au lieu de les vendre en temps
de pénurie il n'ya pas il n'y a jamais
eu de stock caché il y a des commandes
massives et il faut un certain temps
avant qu'elle se concrétise en millions
de masques disponibles pour l'ensemble
de nos concitoyens pour tous ceux qui
pensent qu'il suffit de commander des
masques pour les obtenir
j'ai un long historique dont je peux
faire état mais ce qui compte pour
l'instant c'est que le 11 mai chacun
puisse se procurer des masques dans les
commerces situés près de chez lui nous
avons écouté les associations d'élus et
nous resterons extrêmement attentif à
toutes les remontées du terrain
l'état